let's talk about how to diagnose your
liver by using your foot of course we're
not actually diagnosing the liver you
have to go to the doctor for that but
you can get a lot of Clues by looking at
certain parts of the body especially the
foot to be able to understand what's
going on on the inside versus taking
every one of these Clues and treating
them directly with a different
medication or a skin cream or maybe even
a diuretic because you have edema so
today that kind of really connect the
dots with a lot of different symptoms
that relate to the foot so let's start
off with these red and brown spots in
the lower part of your leg you probably
have seen that with people with diabetes
which they usually have liver problems
but if someone has like therosis or
hepatitis or even a severe fatty liver a
lot of times the circulation is so bad
in the lower part of their body you'll
see these little red and like kind of a
rust color brown maybe sometimes scaly
uh little dots or pigments that looks a
little bit like a bruising so the liver
has a lot to do with the clotting
factors vitamin K and when you lose the
liver function you can have a lot of uh
things like bruising and discolored uh
spots in different parts of your body
and you'll also notice that the lower
leg is very swollen and shiny and
there's no hair growth anymore and you
probably also notice that the skin is
very thin almost like paper thin and
that's partly because of the swollen
nature of the fluid retention as well as
the poor circulation to feed the hairs
and the appropriate amount of protein
that your liver is supposed to make to
allow this collagen to form in your skin
a lot of times you also see pitting
edema so you press your finger into the
lower leg and it leaves a dent I mean
I'm 58 years old right now when I was in
my 30s I had a bit of pinning edema and
I look back I'm like wow I had no idea
that my liver was pretty bad back then
and now I have zero edema you can press
in my lower ankle there's no more
pitting edema so I do want to say the
liver is one of the only organs that has
the potential to completely regenerate
if you get it in time it's not always
about a liver transplant you can do
something about it and then we also have
um some spider veins not just in the
lower ankle but it could be anywhere in
the body so this is a certain situation
where the liver is no longer able to to
regulate estrogen so we have this
unregulated excessive amount of estrogen
that floats around the body and estrogen
tends to Vaso dilate and kind of create
this uh vascular pooling effect of your
blood and the problem with having this
extra estrogen is that extra estrogen
can then damage the liver and create
things like even a fatty liver and
problems with your bod duct which could
lead to um gallstones this is why uh
when a woman is pregnant um they're more
susceptible to getting G Stones because
the higher level of estrogen that can
occur same thing goes with birth control
pills okay what about dry cracked heels
or just dry feet in general that is
usually a very severe omega-3 deficiency
because the liver makes bile and bile
helps you break down and absorb fat
soluble vitamins as well as fat cable
nutrients like the omega-3 fatty acids
that you would get if you're going to
eat like salmon or sardines so bile
helps break down those fats so then you
can actually absorb the omega3 and get
the benefit but with poor liver function
we don't produce the amount of bile that
we need to help to extract the omega-3
fatty acids it can also be a vitamin B3
deficiency which could lead to pgra
that's more rare but you usually see
that where people are just eating the
majority of their calories from corn
corn chips corn tortillas because corn
is very deficient in B3 and that can
create more of a problem with that but
typically if it's in the heel area or
the foot think omega3 fatty acids now
you can also have itching feet this
usually exists because that bile that's
produced by the liver is very very
thickened in like sludge and it's
backing up into the liver and then it's
backing into the blood and then from the
blood it backs into the tissues and that
can show up as itching okay and I know
some people that have this unbearable
itching feet drives them crazy all night
long but they're not making the
connection the problem is probably not
in the foot it's in the liver but it can
also be a fungus growing on the foot uh
people with liver problems have more
fungal infections not just on the foot
but on the toenail as well why because a
really big part of the function of your
liver is immunity there are certain
cells in your liver that are immune
cells you can almost think of the liver
as as kind of like a lymphatic uh tissue
with these small little lymph nodes that
are like little sinuses all over because
it has to deal with all the stuff coming
through the blood as well as through
digestion so it's kind of a hub of the
immune system and so when that goes down
and you lose that function then you get
this overgrowth of candida fungus not
just in your body but outside the body
as well as well as giving you a symptom
of more infl infation because the big
part of your immune system is to counter
inflammation and so there's a huge
correlation between bad sick liver and
arthritis especially if it's like an
infectious arthritis because there's
some type of pathogen floating around
that kind of gets lodged into your
joints it could be in the ankle it could
be in the toe it can be in the knee any
joint and that arthritis is coming
because your immune system is not
working to be able to get rid of the
pathogen so we lose this immune control
and then we have this excessive immune
reaction that creates a lot of
collateral damage like inflammation your
knee because immune system is like a
bowl in a china shop just basically
destroying everything in its vicinity so
in that case it's like your own immune
system that's creating the problem
because it's not able to kill the
pathogen you know quite a few people who
have planer fasciitis this pain in the
bottom of the foot you know get it
treated it doesn't seem to work it's not
really coming from damage in the area
itself a lot of times it's referred from
your liver because you have a tendency
to have more arthritis or inflammation
especially in areas that you're
constantly irritating like your foot
where you're constantly have to walk on
it it creates a lot of inflammation so
in the morning it might be better but at
night your feet are killing you now
because of the poor circulation and the
lack of uh blood flow and things you
you're going to have a tendency to have
buildup of toxic material and it's going
to have bad odor and it will come to the
skin it could be like a a bad uh ammonia
smell and also the temperature is not
regulated so you may notice that your
feet are more hot than they should be so
at night you can't have a blanket on
your foot but on the flip side with some
people that have liver
damage they have cold feet okay and
that's probably because the thyroid
needs to convert at least 80% of its
hormones through the Li Li from T4 to T3
the active form of the thyroid hormone
so if there's liver problems and you
can't make that conversion you end up on
the cold side so too cold too hot could
be liver issues now what about fungus on
your toenail and in between the toes
right where becomes so red and irritated
and painful that people put all sorts of
creams and antibiotics on it yet it
keeps coming back and back and back why
because you haven't got rid of the root
problem you haven't healed the liver so
the immune system can work instead we
treat symptoms add another antibiotic
antifungal and you're better for a while
until it comes right back until you
develop this fungal resistant strain now
that you can't even kill it now also
realize for any type of systemic or
topical fungal problems you can't use an
antibiotic cream or an antibiotic
antibiotics only kill bacteria not
fungus and as a side note there's a lot
of natural things that I have on the
internet uh that are antifungal and
they're natural and they don't have side
effects iodine is one of them tea tree
oil is another one now a really good
clue for liver problems if the toenail
is really healthy chances are your liver
is very healthy and there's a lot of
different problems that can happen with
that toenail number one you can have
something called a dropic nail which is
a nail that's very thick it's cracking
it's distorted it's yellow sometimes it
breaks off from the nail bed it can be
very uncomfortable with just a little
bit of uh force and a person kind of
stubs her toe and then the nail just
starts breaking off so that's one
situation you have another situation
where you have a toenail fungus that's
called anco micosis not that you need to
know that but the nail bed just starts
to break down because there's this
fungus invading and there's a bit of a
yellow coloring but that fungus is
living off of your protein the the
collagen in your nail and this is not
just athletes foot this is not just you
know having your foot in a moist
environment it really has to do with
your own immune defenses internally
that's making it very very weak making
you susceptible to getting uh a fungus
and then you have other types of nail
problems I'm not going to even try to
pronounce these but white lines that go
across or little dots or vertical ridges
that go up and down both of those
situations can be a liver problem also
having a club nail could be a liver
problem and in that situation it's kind
of an upside down spoon so you have this
kind of a squarish very large kind of a
bulbous nail that's occurring on your
foot or it could be in the hand so as
you can see there's a lot of little
clues that you can get by looking at
someone's foot of course if you're doing
this in public on someone's foot don't
mention my name couple little points
liver is a major immune organ number two
the gut floor imbalance if there's any
type of imbalance in your good bacteria
that can make the liver worse there's
this huge uh it's called a gut liver
axis it's a two-way a street situation
where the gut and the liver are under
constant communication so one problem
can create another and then the liver
problem can create problems with your
gut and this is why when someone someone
takes antibiotics they end up with liver
problems and this is also why some
people that are exposed to a lot of
chronic artificial sweeteners right
they're taking a lot of this over a
period of time the synthetic artificial
sweeteners uh a lot of times develop
problems in the gut which then can
create liver problems and even insulin
resistance issues and metabolic syndrome
in fact there's a condition called
rosacea where the person has this like
red cheeks and sometimes a red nose and
of course if you look this up they don't
know what causes it but it could be
related to um an imbalance with your
microbiome because if you have a
condition called small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth bacteria in your
small intestine and you get an
antibiotic to kill it off a lot of times
that clears up in your face well this
makes a lot of sense because when you
have this imbalance of microbes in your
gut what do you think that's going to do
to an imbalance with microbes on the
surface of your skin the main type of
treatment for rosacea mostly involve
topical and internal
antibiotics so it must have something to
do with the microbes either internally
or externally the point is that if
you're going to treat something like
that with an antibiotic what happens
when you destroy all these microbes and
then the problem just comes right back
you keep doing this this is again just
treating the symptom but not the root
cause one last Point um one of the first
signs of liver damage really shows up in
your skin and probably the reason why it
would show up in your foot is because
the foot gets the least blood flow and
so problems show up probably more
commonly than in other places now the
question is what are the best foods to
reverse liver damage okay for that
information you should check this video
up right
here